my name is Manohar so gamer filmmaker
and I'm showing knowing behold reveries
of the connected world it's a film about
the Internet
I don't have a cellphone I hardly use ur
internet so don't have a Twitter account
I know what Facebook is all about I
decided not to sign up
I would walk away from the dinner table
and I would not have dinner with you
again unless you left your cell phone
behind I would just leave you alone with
your steak now why shouldn't you
contribute to to Kickstarter here I
personally prefer people who take
initiative and they do work
I tell them earn money as a bouncer in a
sex club I don't even know what it is
but do I think about it let let them
keep smiling I don't care
if you if you go into an online-dating
you're better now it's stylized versions
invented versions of self you don't even
know if a robot is answering you don't
even know if a dog sits at the laptop
and it writes back to you I don't do any
selfies because I do not have a cell
phone